after we tape this uh i'm gonna run to  the airport  jump on a plane and go to israel that's  what i'm gonna do  [Applause]  we can't afford too much of that song  okay  see that's right while you're watching  this show right now on thursday night i  am on a flight  mid-flight to tel aviv okay and i'm  heading there  to israel to tape one of my conan  without borders  travel shows very excited about that so  yeah should be fun  now hit it guys  [Music]  [Applause]  hit it  anyway while i'm in israel for the next  week i'm going to be documenting my trip  you can follow along live on facebook  instagram  and snapchat so be sure to check out  my adventures live in israel and then  watch the primetime special conan  in israel coming in september  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  uh  they're very good  you